what's up squad fan I'm so tired for
this game it's made by the same people
that made broforce genital jousting and
now they made one for beer called gore
I try to get this game working a few
days ago and I'm like okay I can't get
to work I can't get to what I'm not
smart enough
look at my setup this is what it took to
get this to work god bless you VR you
really innovated something didn't you
Wow now if you some reason have a VR
device you have to get this game ok this
is so fun I watched Jack to play it it's
super fun actually
I actually recommend checking him
playing it out if you haven't watched me
play would you haven't so check me out
first I'm more deformed you're here now
ok let this play let's play it I just
want to play it I just really really
really want to play it alright I can
change the options over there ah I don't
know I guess I'll just keep going into
battle oh my god I get amazed now I must
like you yeah well not here somewhere
oh come on come on I have the power of
God and enemy by my side ah so that God
okay okay don't get me I had the power
No block block block again again what
you gonna do block block
I just hit something I will [ __ ]
yes yeah ah
goddamn I'm good at this this is a good
exercise I gotta say another one please
this is so fun
what'd I do wrong let it go
where's what I saw was right that that
was a mess right there I look super
dangerous I'm running I'm running okay I
think I know maybe next time we'll pick
up the actual weapon well there we go
thank you yeah I'm ready what am i
wiping the less let me just disappear
come on you what's up huh what's up MA
what'd I say wait for you there
oh my god come on me listen your boy
listen yeah boy you don't want to miss
Rooney more did he serve to kill me
charging this one
charging this one come on
ah come on that's mine run run Philips
run their Kingdom good a message this
and all this work all right let's take
their system
how you doing cool Oh God I think he's
dead oh no no [ __ ] yeah
block clock yeah good night come in come
in yeah no I kill them okay
you got way too easy in this game
the Justice plane a few moments later
step 3 oh yes right then what else other
work so well you're not get your time
my name is Morpheus Georgia driving us a
story yes it was that yeah that's what
but that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
are you kidding me Oh stupid I'm getting
sweaty playing video games with a sound
like this come on this is so hard
[Music]
yeah no stop me bad boy bad boy you're
done what I get huh what yeah not a
double I got it
no um your cat yes all right
oh thank you though so hard my god yeah
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you
yeah yes Telefunken region I love the
spirit amazing come on
I have the power of God and anime on my
side oh my God look at that fish
I'm dying world
I was so fun oh my joy alright guys
that's it for me for now thank you for
leaving a like in this video and then
gender fixed